isn't any franchise of Stargate at risk
because of Amazon's dithering welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
so we've been covering the Revival of
Stargate for well over a year we've been
lucky enough to be able to drop you guys
news first and exclusive over and over
again about the plans Revival of
Stargate and what looks like going to be
a cinematic movie
but I've also been able to drop you lots
of news about lots of dithering so let's
go back to the beginning on this one and
recap it really quickly Brad Wright had
written a script for a pilot of the
Stargate series it was done it was ready
to go but then we had covid-19 damn you
covered 19. and we had two years of well
nothing literally nothing we weren't
allowed him to go out
so that never got made during that
period Amazon decided that they were
definitely going to buy MGM and not long
after really the pandemic ended that
sale is finalized when Amazon then went
in to MGM they found a company really
not in the state that they wanted lots
and lots of creative issues that they
saw and a business that wasn't being run
in away that they thought was
appropriate or efficient they have
basically now absorbed MGM into Amazon
Prime now MGM really isn't a standalone
company anymore everything it does is
done through Prime head of MGM pictures
is Jennifer sulky head of MGM movies or
film is Courtney Valentini now I think
she is a new employee by Amazon but
she's also the head of film for Amazon
Prime so really she's just the head of
Amazon Prime with really an MGM
subsidiary lobbed onto the side now I've
also talked to you a lot and it's been a
complete roller coaster I know about how
Amazon just couldn't decide what to do
with Stargate they could have just
allowed MGM to carry on with its plan to
do Brad rights now that's what MGM
initially thought they were going to be
allowed to do they thought they were
going to be allowed to crack on with the
star are gay franchise pretty much as
soon as the sale went through and they
continued planning for that my sources
have actually told me out of MGM that
Amazon kind of encouraged it they kind
of made MGM believe that actually they
were going to be allowed to carry on
working as a separate entity that Amazon
was just going to come in and behave
like a customer well we found out very
quickly that that just wasn't true and
was never going to happen probably
Amazon blamed covid-19 like all the big
companies have blamed it for everything
but I mean In fairness the country and
the world did shut down for two years so
they probably got a point
but Amazon blamed that on why they had
to restructure MGM and they had to
absorb it into Amazon Prime
so
all of those big promises were renegdon
and we are now where we are then Amazon
disagreed constantly over whether it
should be a TV series or a movie that
would kick-start the new Stargate
franchise that argument went on and on
but one thing Amazon did seem to do
early on which was a good thing and
celebrated and again announced first
here
was they got Mark Fergus involved in the
franchise now very early on they got
Mark Fergus to do the Bible for the
series now this is a document basically
that was given to companies that were
then going to pitch for the Stargate
franchise companies like Bad Robot and
penguin and Parker Mark fergus's company
it was a document that basically tells
them what Stargate is what's the
important Cannon for the series what is
the important points what are the bits
that make Stargate Stargate and what are
the areas that they can maybe fudge a
little bit if they wanted to make
changes that Bible was given to those
companies and they used it as their
Foundation that they then built their
pictures off
Mark Fergus did that work Mark Fergus
was actually the person that came to
Stargate in the first place at the end
of the expanse Jenny stiven has actually
confirmed this on dial the gate she said
after the expanse Amazon executive said
look what would you like to do next Mark
and Mark Fergus went I'd love to take a
bite out of Stargate please and it
seemed that they were going to let him
because we were able to tell you just
before Christmas that they were actually
negotiating Mark Fergus was talking to
Amazon they were trying to figure out
things like budgets Mark Fergus was
asking for 10 million dollars an episode
Amazon was saying five
but the negotiations were going ahead
and they were probably going to drop
somewhere in the region of seven to
eight that's really a decent budget sort
of in line with what Star Trek gets
but then negotiations just stopped just
before Christmas Mark Fergus apparently
was getting a little bit frustrated over
the budget negotiations he was getting a
little bit frustrated mainly though
because according to my sources by the
fact that Amazon wouldn't tell him what
they actually wanted was it a movie was
it a series is it going to be 10
episodes what streaming service is then
going to pick it up is it MGM Plus or is
it Amazon Prime
what do you want and Amazon couldn't
tell him so negotiations amicably I'm
told ended just before Christmas
now the concern is and I've shared this
with you a couple of times before
already that those negotiations don't
seem to have restarted and it's now June
so what is going on well I have been
told by a couple of people actually that
Mark Fergus was just asked to
concentrate on God of War they knew the
righteous strike was coming so they just
basically said get God of War done we
want to be able to film that pretty much
this summer would oddly start
pre-production if the writers are on
strike you can't do any more scripts so
just get them done get the all that
development work done and we can crack
on with that at least we can get one
thing going rather than having two
projects half done we want one done now
he seems to have achieved that goal but
now I'm told he wants to crack on with
developing Stargate and he's again
hitting a brick wall now it seems that
again Amazon are dithering they don't
seem to know which production company
they want to go with to produce the
Stargate franchise we've talked about
how it could be Warner Brothers it could
be Sony there are other options there
are other names floating around rumored
as well now why is that a problem well
if they go with Warner Brothers for
example Warner Brothers may push for
them to go with Bad Robot to develop and
actually create the show
Warner Brothers may not want to work
with penguin in a Parker now Sony does
work with penguin and Parker so they
probably would be more than happy to do
that in the future as well they're doing
God of War together already
but because Amazon can't make the
decision because of the dithering Mark
Fergus is becoming increasingly
frustrated
they could actually Lose the person that
in my mind could actually give Stargate
its best opportunity for Success now if
they're not going to bring Brad writing
which for me would be a no-brainer
getting somebody like Mark Fergus and
Hawk ospi that he works with at penguin
and Parker the people that did such a
great job with the expanse get them
involved in this
somebody that we know is a big fan of
Stargate he asked for the project in the
first place this is a team that could
actually do justice to this franchise
and they could be about to lose them
Mark Fergus could walk away now
apparently he is frustrated that he
wants to crack on if they're going to do
a cinematic movie he wants to get the
script finalized apparently there is a
working script knocking around so
maybe we're closer to that than we think
but I'm told he wants to get it final he
wants a team MGM in place and it looks
like Amazon are actually starting to do
that as they're starting to talk to
people through MGM that could actually
create that management and that creative
production team
it looks like they're going in the right
direction but are they just going to
down slowly well I'd argue yes but
obviously we do live in a world right
now in Hollywood that is complicated to
say the least
and it was only at roughly I think it
was March that actually MGM hired that
Courtney Valentini that lady that's
going to actually run MGM movies so if
they are doing a movie that's basically
what they were waiting for but guys I'd
love for you to get into the comments
and tell me what you think have Amazon
been dithering over this or have they
actually just been having to do all this
hard work to get MGM in a position where
MGM can make movies again
and make movies profitably
or is this just one more example of
Amazon acting like a business rather
than a studio and a company that creates
entertainment
they took a very long time with rings of
power some people would say too long and
they actually had a situation of too
many cooks spoiled broth are we at risk
of them doing the same thing with
Stargate I'd love to know exactly what
you think so get in the comments
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you can also go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where this video aired
first and for a small contribution each
month you can see it without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]